most of us would love to score a first
class seat on a commercial flight but
how about the chance to own one it is
one of several items that Shoppers found
next to Atlanta's Hartsfield-Jackson
airport in a garage sale of sorts Chris
Van Cleef visited the site to speak with
Airline enthusiasts about why they're
opening their wallets to buy some
Airline leftovers
it was early Friday morning a few weeks
before Christmas when in the shadow of
the country's busiest airport a line of
creatures were stirring but it wasn't
hope Saint Nicholas would soon be there
that had these dozens gathered instead
of visions of sugar plums its hopes of a
First-Class seat dancing in their heads
Santa's Workshop this old Maintenance
building is not you're excited to shop
but for an aviation fan it comes close
does the December sale is that a special
one for you yes people come in the
mindset of okay I need gifts I need
stocking stuffers for the last 17 years
Judy Bean has run what amounts to a very
unique giant monthly garage sale
consisting of all kinds of stuff Delta
Airlines doesn't need any more like old
overhead bins a cockpit jump seat
someone once paid 500 for a cabin door
from a dc-9 so one airline's junk is
another man's treasure exactly that's
exactly right when somebody cleans out a
closet if they have stuff they're
trained now to contact me and I never
say no be it extra plates leftover Delta
swag or a row of first-class seats for
300 bucks exactly why Ron Newton drove
to Atlanta from South Carolina it just
brings back a lot of memories of the
travel time we used to fly over the
Great Atlantic Ocean and one of the big
747s and it just brings back a lot of
memories and going fast was something
that's rather heavy dozens of engine fan
blades yours for 25 to 75 dollars a
piece depending on condition what are
you going to do with a fan blade set it
on a shelf somewhere looks good right
it's expensive without being expensive
it's a bit Supermarket Sweep meets
treasure hunt just in time for the
holidays
Richard and Angela Shepard came to
finish off their holiday shopping where
else could you get an infant life vest
as a baby gift hilarious yeah if you
can't buy turban blades in a store so
it's pretty cool and uh our son and
daughter-in-law are both Pilots so we
thought this would be kind of a cool
gift for him how much of your family did
you check off the list today
yeah we did pretty good Delta is the
only U.S airline holding this kind of
sale all the proceeds including the more
than fifteen thousand dollars from this
day goes to support the Delta Flight
Museum for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Atlanta
uh so what do you think would you buy
something there no I would definitely
buy something I think it
I think what would you buy if I hit the
Mega Millions I would buy I don't need
mega millions and you'd want a door for
five bucks I do a whole theater in my
house not that I have a big house out of
first class seats I like that and I have
to buy and then people would come to
your house and complain and they'd be
like Adriana these seats are not very
comfortable they're like but let's see
as a father and Vlad you might want to
use this I would get the intercom system
you know I'd come in this is your dad's
speaker
please clean up the kitchen and put your
technology away yeah you're starting our
descent to the bedroom good night that's
what I want get everybody very cool